hey one guys pull this move they go hey
you know I I had sex with that girl I'm
the man and you go yeah well she had sex
with him too and like oh what a
well that's not fair how come she's a
now how come she want to when
she banged you you never hear a guy say
that oh she slept with me
what a this
this is a wake-up call
I feel like we're so mean to promiscuous
girls in this Society aren't we
she's loose she's easy well what
is that don't we all like sex where I'm
getting mad at the one group giving it
away yeah we all like Banana Republic
but they have a sale nobody calls them a
the are still oppressed
that's the one group in this country
that still gets stepped on and I'm the
only guys sticking up for these women
even women won't stick up for him those
are ruin it for everybody no you
could
put out too
because let's be honest you know prude
girls they're like Mom and Pop shops we
all pretend to like them but they're
more expensive and they close early
promiscuous girls are like Walmart all
right everybody makes fun of them
everybody talks down to them when you're
inside one at four in the morning you're
like man I'm glad these are around